je me dis que le sang que j'ai vu ce
soir là m'a marqué
qui est arrivé après cette soirée
ne peut pas être une simple coïncidence
[Musique]
vous n'avez pas l'air de quelqu'un
dangereux
racontez-moi comment vous vous êtes
retrouvé là
[Musique]
je vais te défoncer tu vas voir
allez vous
sur la figure
tu es en sécurité ça ne vous a pas paru
bizarre que cet homme surgisse de nulle
part pour vous aider je me suis dit que
ça fait de la chance vous avez déjà eu
de la chance
de lutte on a trouvé du sang par terre
la fille aucune trace d'elle nulle part
à mon avis la descendue
il a pas tiré dans le Tao hasard il
cache quelque chose
que s'est-il passé dans cette maison où
est-ce qu'ils sont tous passés
des espèces invisibles
ce ne sont pas les seules personnes
proches de vous avoir disparu n'est-ce
pas tu crois que ce sont toutes des
victimes
tout ce qui s'est passé semble être
votre idée depuis le début vous croyez
que c'est moi qui tire les ficelles dans
l'histoire
je vous disais oui c'est pas moi
Dany je suis là pour vous aider j'ai pas
tiré la meilleure chose à faire
imagine que j'ai raison Daniel
qu'est-ce que vous me cachez
qu'est-ce que vous vous cachez à
vous-même